hi I'm Paul I'm an architect I've been
doing this for six years my name is
magar star vaz and i've been an interior
architect for six years now I've built a
gingerbread house probably when I was
eight and ever since then I just eat the
ones that people build I haven't built a
gingerbread house like this before yeah
see how this goes
can I eat this yeah let's lay the
foundation down to get this thing to
stick I don't know if it's gonna work
but I'm doing something cuz it's yeah
this is gonna everything who's gonna
keep following over from oh it's in a
seismically unsafe zone in California so
I'm gonna use the template yeah I was
thinking about putting the floor down
put a room right here I'm gonna get
super messy don't judge me honey the
roof is running so don't care there's
some holes we'll just cover it with a
little man I wanted to do a bunch of
other stuff I don't know how far I'm
gonna get cuz everything nothing sets
everything just kind of collapses like
this was supposed to be a Christmas tree
and it's mostly just things I'm eating
now can I put them in an appropriate
positions sure it can be inappropriate
yeah yes we go we get what's going on I
wanted to cut open some of the
gingerbread to make like a big window to
treat inside but it's barely sticking
together as it is and see that I have
these little straws as columns holding
it up because otherwise the roof isn't
gonna stay up you come in through the
front door there's glass right here
there's a room underneath here an
entryway another room back here and a
small little area back here if you look
over here there's little bamboo that
covers the glass behind
have a nice little patio area with my
friends keeping busy and the little pool
area and that's pretty much it it's a
very modern contemporary look so I guess
in the end I was able to make a bleeding
house
I could feel pretty awesome and I really
want to go build another one I mean I
did this once before and it don't
remember it being so hard just to keep
it all together so I'm a little sad but
it's standing pretty difficult it's
really messy but it's pretty fun and
it's rewarding because you get to eat it
when we're done the end of the day I
didn't kill anybody
so I think to wrap up I'm gonna decorate
this dude with the sad face